the tick tock users
are now mimicking the politicians trades
this is hilarious well nancy pelosi is
the best options trader of all time so
ever ever of all time so why wouldn't
you just copy it if you're a politician
you become worth a hundred million
dollars it's like a rule in america like
become a politician win the campaign
you're immediately worth a hundred
million dollars why because you just
happen to be gum good at trump no one
really knows what happens
queen of investing
[Laughter]
all right so here's what's going on
young investors have started to trade by
watching the financial disclosures of
sitting members of congress for stock
tips uh a law called the stock act
requires lawmakers to disclose stock
trades and those of their spouses within
45 days why is it 45 days probably
because it allows them to get away with
a bunch of nonsense if you do the trade
you should just report it immediately so
far this year senate and house members
have filed more than 4 000 trading uh
financial disclosures with at least 315
million dollars of stocks and bonds
bought or sold where are they coming up
with hundreds of millions of dollars to
be yoloing into stocks and bonds at the
same time that literally unemployment is
off the charts we've got 11 million open
jobs in the country we've got people who
are suffering 45 of the uh entire
population doesn't own a single stock or
investment yet our politicians think
that they're uh gordon gecko day trading
it's absolutely absurd according to a
survey done this year by data for
progress 67 percent of americans believe
federal lawmakers should not own
individual stocks we'll get to that in a
second we've got a quote i think i don't
know i wasn't here for the pre part but
we're going to find out congressman raja
krishnam murthy damn i'm sorry i don't
know how to pronounce it krishna
morty i think is probably close as i
understand it one of the perks of being
a member of congress especially from the
late 1800s on was to be able to trade on
inside information that was a perk of
being in congress and it has to come to
an end it can't be a real quote it is
that's not a reason you proposed a bill
that they shouldn't be allowed to trade
stocks and bonds i mean you have a
sitting congressman who just said one of
the perks of being a member of congress
was to be able to trade on insider
information
do you need any other proof he's like
there's nothing wrong with that
he's like we need to stop it now that's
how it was in the past do you literally
an insider is telling you that they're
insider trading it's a perk of being a
congress person do we need any other
proof that we should just stop talking
about this but you want to know who the
genius you get two weeks vacation free
parking and insider training
do you want to know who the geniuses and
these stories are the tick tockers by
far
literally like oh cool you guys are
going to go long and make money so are
we they're literally just taking the
exact stock investment disclosures and
they're just replicating them in their
own portfolios and then going on the
internet and saying things like whale
alert or the queen of investing or how
to join the exclusive group chat at uh
shout out at the end i don't know what
that means u.s is uh an agreement to
purchase a
with these different things so the
second that you start to understand
the second you start to understand
what's going on here you first have to
ask the question uh are the politicians
doing anything illegal no to be clear as
far as we know no one is doing anything
illegal why because they're not trading
on inside information of
material information inside the company
what they're doing is they're trading on
information that is going to affect the
company it's an external piece of
information but that happens to have a
really really big part of uh the
implications on that stock so for
example if i know that we're gonna over
regulate an industry i'm probably gonna
sell the stock if i know we're gonna
loosen regulation on an industry i'm
probably gonna buy the stock if i know
maybe for example that there maybe
possibly was a private uh update that
was given in a presentation about how
bad covid really was but we haven't
haven't yet told the public and then
accidentally somewhere maybe somebody
who controlled my money made a trade is
that a problem well what if i didn't
tell them what if maybe somehow else
they knew that there was a presentation
that said that there's lots and lots of
complexity lots of questions lots of
nuance but it begs the question should
politicians own individual stocks if you
believe like the mainstream media does a
journalist should not own individual
stocks because it presents a conflict of
interest and therefore the journalists
out of the sacrifice of doing their job
refuses to own individual stocks and
instead only buys low-cost index funds
or mutual funds or holds no investments
then why do we hold journalists to a
higher standard than the politicians
that are elected by the people in order
to govern what we do on a daily basis we
literally hold journalists to a higher
standard on conflict of interest than we
do the politicians maybe we should all
the politicians to just the same level
of scrutiny and rules that we hold
journalists do now on top of that what
becomes even more interesting is
why is it that not only are you allowed
to hold stock
in a certain company but on top of that
that company can actually back your
campaign and then you can regulate that
industry so let's say for example i'll
just pick on a company that seems to be
doing well uh pfizer in the healthcare
space
pfizer could donate to my campaign i
then could use their capital along with
other donors go win an elected seat and
then turn around and i could be the
health care regulator i could have a
hand in crafting legislation that
affects that business the executives or
that industry do you think i'm gonna be
overly really worried about being
aggressive do you think i'm gonna be on
bias no they literally paid to put me in
this position so here's what i think we
should do one politicians if you become
a politician you can't have any
investments why because not we don't
want you to get rich we actually should
just pay you enough money we're holding
investments isn't gonna matter just pay
them five million dollars each a year
literally just go pay them cash and say
you can't hold any investments you can't
have any jobs can't write any books
can't do anything as nonsense while
you're in office we'll just give you a
big paycheck and then we don't have to
worry about you wanting to get rich
anywhere else you're already greedy and
you're going to get a big paycheck and
then you're not going to have any
conflict of interest the second thing is
if you have a large percentage of your
campaign that is contributed from a
certain industry you should not be able
to influence or regulate or or legislate
that industry while you are in office
it's not that hard the banks put you in
office you shouldn't be allowed to come
up with banking legislation if the
pharma industry puts you in office you
should be able to come up with pharma
legislation just allow for the most
unbiased environment possible put the
rules in place
tell these people who are buying and
selling hundreds of millions of dollars
of stocks and bonds knock it off get
back to governing and maybe we'd get a
couple more things done in washington
rather than them worried about how big
their day trading portfolios are hey
guys bang bang thanks so much for
watching the best business show today
and don't forget to check out our
partner sofi they make all this possible
they're a super app that lets you save
spend borrow earn and invest all from
one single platform and if you go there
today and you sign up for a sofi invest
account you can get between five dollars
and a thousand bucks for free from sofa
not everyone's obviously gonna get a
thousand dollars but everyone gets
something don't say that i never did
anything for you go check them out at
sofi.com
download the app and go ahead and open
an account sofi.compomp
and make sure you come back and watch
more the best business show we're going
to build the biggest business show in
the world and we need your help
[Music]